hey this is very very interesting we're
continuing to cover
the soft about face happening on Fox
news with regard to the failed former
president Donald Trump's new candidacy
in 2024 and Fox and Friends host Brian
Kilmeade is really at the center of a
lot of this and what is taking place you
know sometimes there's this feeling in
when you do what I do
that we have to explain a phenomenon in
the absolute most extreme black and
white terms fox has completely abandoned
Trump and is now hostile to him and will
do anything they can to prevent him from
being president no that's not what
happened what is happening on Fox is
that a number of hosts Brian Kilmeade is
certainly one of them have done a soft
turn away from Trump where it seems
pretty clear that even if it's not about
personally what they want but as they're
as their the role that they play on
their Channel dictates
they want to be friendly to the idea of
a DeSantis a candidacy and presidency if
it doesn't happen they're not going to
completely cut Trump off such that they
have no access to him if Trump really is
going to be president for another four
years Fox would be very poorly
positioned uh if they lost access to
Trump because of you know adversarial or
antagonistic relationships on the the
other hand
they do want to be there
if indeed someone else takes control of
the Republican party and ultimately the
presidency like Ron DeSantis but and so
we've seen Brian kill me do a number of
different things go out on the street
and try to find DeSantis supporters or
play catch with Ron DeSantis in a total
softball interview as we looked at
yesterday this sort of thing
here is something that actually did
surprise me a little bit which is that
Brian Kilmeade brings up
Trump now seems more disciplined than he
did at one point like for example
compared to when he had lunch with white
supremacists it is genuinely surprising
to me that Brian Kilmeade is even
willing to acknowledge that take a look
at this segment since he went and
visited East Palestine uh stopped having
lunch with white supremacists and has
got a very disciplined message according
to the Emerson poll he's got 73 percent
uh approval rating among Republicans
with high school with high school
degrees or below and he's winning in
almost every state outside California
and I'll add this to it it would be
interesting if he does not win Iowa and
you go to and and Governor sununu gets
into New Hampshire and Governor soon is
so popular winning three terms as
Governor there he could be out and on a
bit of a roll this is the most
discipline I've ever seen him even
compared to 2016. if you see his team
you get text messages every day okay so
he said this is the most disciplined
I've seen Trump since he stopped having
lunch with white supremacists or as
Brian Kilmeade calls them supremists
which is a different word but I totally
understand what Brian Kilmeade means
this is the Trump pivot
that remember is a conditional pivot
it's a tentative pivot it's a sort of
depending on what happens pivot we'd
kind of rather someone other than Trump
be the nominee
but if it is Trump we can't totally
abandon him because we're going to want
access for the next four years now this
is quite a low Bar for a presidential
candidate right it's an understatement
to call this a low bar Trump has never
seemed this disciplined uh particularly
since he stopped having lunches with
white supremacists the you know the
mainstream media won't tell you but guys
it's been months since Trump lasted
dined with white supremacist and we've
got to give them credit for that it is a
stunningly low bar but it is a little
bit surprising to what degree that Brian
kilmead is even talking about the white
supremacist lunch and it does seem like
another one of those subtle digs we'd
rather someone else but I'm also framing
this as a positive thing we'd rather
someone else but Trump is looking pretty
damn disciplined at this point in time
super interesting and fox of course
wants to host Republican primary debates
when they get going never mind
presidential debates and so to some
degree they have to do this now if we
look at the latest polling what does the
polling say about what's going on it's
really a mixed bag there's a new morning
consult poll rated B minus where Trump
is winning over DeSantis by 24. that's a
poll that includes a ton of other people
including Pence and Haley and Liz Cheney
and Abbott and a whole bunch of
different people there's a new CNN SSRS
poll not as well rated of a poll that
one's a c plus c plus B minus is pretty
similar that one has DeSantis ahead of
trump even with the inclusion of Nikki
Haley and Mike Pence and Tim Scott and a
bunch of other people these are two
polls conducted essentially at the same
time by very similarly ranked pollsters
with a 26 Point difference Trump plus 24
versus DeSantis plus two
uh very very interesting but it cannot
be ignored that the vast majority of
these polls public policy polling
premise University of North Florida is
an exception and that's looking
specifically at Florida but in the
National polling Trump's winning most of
them even with this outlier CNN poll so
Fox News is doing what Fox News is most
uh inclined to do how do we maintain
access for future profitability and
ratings that is at the end of the day
the number one priority that explains
Fox hosts caught in text messages
acknowledging that all of the election
lies were indeed lies but saying our
viewers believe something else and so
we've got to keep going with that
narrative on TV expect this to continue
and it is really wacky stuff that Brian
kilmead clip will be on my YouTube
channel which you can find at
youtube.com slash the David Pacman show
and a Spanish version of this very story
will be on the Spanish YouTube channel
which you can find at davidpackman.com
Spanish
plastic it's everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year here's something super
simple you can do to reduce plastic and
help the planet a little bit our sponsor
hold on bags is the company making
plastic free trash bags and zip seal
kitchen bags they're just as strong and
high quality as the plastic bags you're
used to hold on bags are 100 percent
plant-based and home compostable meaning
they break down in just weeks not
decades their zip seal kitchen bags come
in sandwich or gallon size to fit all of
your needs whether it's carrots or
crayons at home I put all of my food
waste in a hold on trash bag throw it in
the compost pile and when I throw a hold
on trash bag in my dumpster I love
knowing it's not filling our landfills
and oceans with plastic single use
Plastics harm the planet at every Stage
production disposal decomposition join
the growing movement away from
single-use plastic these products are
really great it's so easy to make the
switch go to hold on bags.com
Pacman and you'll get 20 off with code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below